fortunately to many pain is the only
thing that's real
last night we told you about a Wall
Street Journal story profiling Shoppers
outside a supermarket 60 miles from New
Orleans one of those profiled Megan Nach
one says that prices have gotten so high
she now spends more money on groceries
for her family of eight than on her
fifteen hundred dollar monthly mortgage
Megan knock on joins me now Megan
um how much has your bill gone up in
just the last year long
in the last year definitely a few
hundred dollars
so every time you go shopping every
month what is it
um
we every time we go shall we go shopping
multiple times a week but since within
the last year it's definitely gone up
you know for like a monthly budget
two hundred dollars
and what does Washington mean what does
Megan what does Washington
not get about this for regular Working
Families you saw Biden celebrating when
this inflation number came out at the
White House how does that feel to you
uh not too great I'm sure he doesn't
have to worry about you know putting
food on the table
um
when's it gonna stop when are the rising
prices going to stop not just the
grocery prices but the energy prices
they have our light bill has almost
doubled in the past few months and it
wasn't just a slow progression it was a
month to month like one month it was
regular the next month almost 200 more
and we're like
you know how are the people down here
supposed to afford this
you know
during
um
the pre-pandemic period let's say in
2018 2019 gasoline was it about 2 12 to
20 to 30 a gallon most parts of the
country uh was that more of an
affordable number for you and your
family did you notice if you're able to
save a little bit of money
under those circumstances
well absolutely definitely more
affordable and thank goodness I mean gas
prices have come down just recently
um if you would have had the gas prices
the energy prices the grocery prices
we're just regular people here you know
how are we gonna afford all that
well what about the push for just go get
an electric car does that resonate with
you
not for it makes no sense at all to me
no sense at all
uh they want people to slow down on the
their grids and not use as much energy
but then go get an electric car
well Megan that's Washington for you
this is one this is why I want to get
out of Washington this is yeah this is
they're not listening to the real
victims but now they're not listening to
people
people actual people like you Megan
Megan I really appreciate you joining us
you have a big family to take care of
and a budget to make and uh help is on
the way help is on the way so thank you
very much for being here tonight hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else